jennifer aniston is not pregnant she's
playing a mom with Julia Roberts and
Kate Hudson in their new movie mother's
day it's just all his mother's day
Stefan I have to say yes you haven't
aged that much thank you mom of two gate
had a very special onset experience with
the movie's director Garry Marshall who
is known her since she was just goldie
Hawn's baby girl when I was on overboard
as a kid you know he likes to let the
kids yell out you know action or rolling
and I remember being not little kids on
his set and i watch Rider and he's
sitting with Gary and we both have had a
bit of an emotional moment and Gary just
women congratulation I'm not a contest
winner and why am i hugging yeah Julia
plays a TV host and best-selling author
who forfeits a family for her career jen
is a single mom who finds herself
crushing on single dad Jason Sudeikis
this is the fifth film they've done
together we should just continue off
into the sunset at the rate we've been
doing movies together which is makes it
quite comfortable and fun and familiar
and Jason is raising two daughters on
his own in the movie causing him to
ponder the unthinkable a world with no
mom no no be a bunch of kids running
around with golf clubs and chainsaw us
without my right and that's so my little
boy's life
mom's gone that's not chainsaw let's all
your hedge clipper I like giving the
mamas credit it's all about the mama oh
well mother day opens april 229